g2 you hit the rook and after king g2
there's queen f3 king will have to go to
f1 and bishop f3 is checkmate yeah
exactly this is the final point of of
the combination
is in disbelief right now
yeah but i mean he should really be very
very angry with himself sir i also feel
that you know that the previous game
still had an impact on this yeah that uh
maybe andrea was very although at the
end that he survived that incredible
scare despite being winning at the
beginning
it was a very very big turn around
afterwards
and uh
okay we have to wait for for andre to
make up his mind
i i feel like he's not even he's not
even thinking about the position anymore
he just wants to calm down because okay
this is a complete knockout blow
peter i'm just wondering you start with
the white pieces you play the spanish
what moment do you think it is when
things went so horribly wrong for andre
what was that def uh decisive moment in
the game and andres if yanko throws in
the towel there is nothing to play for
he resigns with this yandapamnishi takes
the lead in their match
yeah he takes and the very very
important